the approach to the role is always the
same
it comes out of the people that you're
working with
and usually strong actresses make it
easier olympia dukakis has died
the iconic actress was 89. on saturday a
rep for the actress told et
quote after months of failing health
olympia dukakis passed away this morning
may 1st at her home in new york city
with her daughter christina zorick by
her side
and tributes have been pouring in for
the late actress
viola davis wrote on twitter quote you
made all around you step up their game
enjoy to work with rest well olympia's
still magnolia co-star sally field told
e.t in a statement quote
everyone loved her she was a gift unique
and talented and one of a kind
john stamos posted this photo to
instagram writing in the caption quote
we lost a great one today olympia's
acclaimed career began in the theater
and later went to the big screen playing
cher's mother in moonstruck
cher took her reaction to olympia's
death to twitter
revealing she spoke with olympia three
weeks before she died
cher wrote quote she was weak but was
happy
what the hell happened to you for this
breakout performance olympia won an
academy award
her husband betrays her and she doesn't
immediately say you did this you did
that to me you betrayed me she
tries to understand it philosophically
she also took a moment in her press room
speech
to praise her on-screen daughter it's
not only her work
that was so fine but she's a person of
real courage
olympia followed up this triumph by
joining the ensemble of her other most
well-known film
still magnolias it's past the cynicism
and
past the sophistication and past
materialism and it just kind of goes to
values that
abide in all of us i think that's what
they feel when they connect with small
towns
on sunday co-star dolly parton told et
in a statement quote
she has been one of my favorite people
that i have ever known or worked with
she added quote she will be missed by
her fans
her family and those of us that were
lucky enough to get to know her
personally
janice van meter got hit with a baseball
it was fabulous
among the many highlights of olympia's
legacy being a champion for women and
older actors in hollywood
at the premiere of still magnolias
olympia told et
how she hoped the movie would have this
positive influence on the industry
also to put to rest the idea that women
you know can't work together
can't really collaborate because this is
really proof of
a wonderful collaboration it begins to
show people that older actresses
are complex and have riches to
share